hey guys it's I'm back at it again today
I'm actually gonna make a giant cotton
candy flower which was also something I
saw on the streets of China it's exactly
as you would imagine it's just layers
and layers of cotton candy until it
builds up into this huge candy flower as
you guys know I am NOT the best at this
but I do give it my best shot let's go
so we have the cotton candy machine the
sugar scooper and we also have different
colored Kon candy sugar start the
Machine you let it warm up I don't
really have a lot of experience making
cotton candy I think I've only made it
once before also in China because they
use skewers instead of cones I'm also
going to be using this I'm just gonna do
a warm-up I'll show you this is a bit
hard okay
that's much prettier it's gonna test
this first one terrified this is your
normal Connie Connie now I need to do a
not normal one the ultimate goal is huge
that's why it's hard 15 layers let's try
this
you just have to spin really fast holy
moly isn't normal
oh I forgot to put water on the stick
it's falling off no no no no I'm getting
cotton candy everywhere and dudas games
they all went on my hand how much is
there this is what is going on right now
I actually don't know how I'm gonna be
able to do this all my stress all my
stress you see let's try it again
[Music]
how did you do this so you kind of just
fold you just so you make it look like a
flower
this is look like a [ __ ] continue you
fold it up like that as long as it looks
like it has five or six petals I have to
make like 50 layers of this this is this
is getting a bit much okay so now I fold
it again I need it oh it looks so good
on camera
we're doing the right thing the key is
to spin really fast that's it so we're
gonna fold it again I feel like it's
about to fall off but that just means me
to keep on going it's too big I feel
like you're beginning to not be able to
see the layers it looks I'm gonna keep
on going this is like a panic attack
every time I'm aiming for 15 we have 1 2
3 4 5
six down nine more to go here we go
Lewis one smells like funky great help
oh did you okay this one's a little
gross but I'm gonna keep on going oh my
god
they have cotton candy all the way up to
my elbow my hand has become part of the
stick so far we have eight this is the
eighth layer feel like it's beginning to
melt
I'm just going to start speed doing this
I feel like I have Kenny all over my
face ten it's starting to look like a
giant dumpling five more I mean I'm
getting delusional I don't go lifting
enough to do this I totally won't like
starting to get a little too big to
handle I think we're pretty much there
should I do one more that is not the
spirit can you see my face
[Music]
why am i why am i doing that white white
nope stop okay one more layer to wrap it
up it's gonna be huge
[Music]
it's done if you're ready started to
blend together at least I got to this
point these people who do it in China
they're super precise they're super
detailed I'm pretty proud and I will see
you all next time I have a lot of sugar
to go through
[Music]